hallo leute heute stellen wir euch die
wichtigsten vokabeln für den körper vor
los geht's das ist der arm das sind die
arme lisa rudert mit den armen
das hier ist ein finger das sind die
finger lisa zeigt mit dem finger auf
mich
das ist ein daumen
das sind die daumen
lisa drückt mir die daumen für meine
bachelorarbeit das ist das bein das sind
die beine
maria steht auf einem bein
das ist der fuß
maria hat zwei füße ich trete maria auf
den fuchs
[Gelächter]
das ist die hand das sind die hände
dieser wink mit der hand das ist ein
rücken
das sind die rücken auch einen rücken
kann entzücken maria tut der rücken weh
[Musik]
das ist der bau
das sind die bäuche lisa hat einen
vollen bauch das ist der hals maria hat
halsschmerzen
das ist die schulter das sind die
schultern
maria zuckt mit den schultern
das ist der kopf
lisa schüttelt mit dem kopf
das ist das ohr das sind die ohren
maria hat unterschiedliche ohren
das ist ein gesicht
harry macht eine grimasse mit ihrem
gesicht das ist das auge das sind die
augen
maria macht gymnastik mit ihren augen
das ist die nase lisa läuft die nase
lisa putzt sich die nase
das ist ein hund lisa macht einen
schmollmund lisa hat einen bart
die sagen basiert ihren bart das sind
die lippen
maria presst ihre lippen zusammen
das ist die stirn
maria runzelt die stirn
das ist ein haar das sind die haare
ich ziehe maria an den haaren
wenn ihr das vokabular noch weiter
vertiefen wollt dann könnt ihr unsere fc
klengen benutzen denn dort gibt es ein
für kabel trainer und viele
weiterführende aufgaben
[Musik]
bis bald
ich trete maria auf dem fuß
[Gelächter]